[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hallweg guten Abend ihnen allen
zu Beginn erstmal ein Hoch auf die
jugendn jawohl denn die U17 ist erstmals
Fußball
weleltmeister in einem finalkrimi setzte
sich das dfbteam gegen Frankreich im
Meter Schießen durch nach der
Europameisterschaft jetzt also auch der
wmtitel gleich mehr dazu es gibt aber
auch noch andere Themen
heute Ringen ums Geld beim Haushalt fürs
nächste Jahr stellt der Finanzminister
Sozialleistungen in Frage SPD und Grüne
lehnen das
ab Ausweitung der Kampfzone nach der
Feuerpause verstärkt die israelische
Armee ihre Angriffe nun auch im Süden
des
Gazastreifens und schneeaos im südlichen
Bayern der Luft Schienen und
Straßenverkehr kommt fast zum Erliegen
auch das Bundesligaspiel Bayern München
gegen Union Berlin fällt
aus in Teilen Bayerns herrscht also
Ausnahmezustand es hat so viel geschneit
dass der Münchner Flughafen dicht ist
etliche Bahnstrecken gesperrt tausende
Haushalte ohne Strom und die Behörden
raten den Menschen dringend zu Hause zu
bleiben den Wald zu meiden und nur im
Notfall ins Auto zu steigen Julian
Schmid fent
die Flieger in München festgesetzt von
den Schneemassen und mit ihnen tausende
Passagiere mindestens bis 6 Uhr morgen
früh bleiben alle Maschinen und Menschen
am Boden manche haben hier ihre erste
Nacht schon hinter
sich ich habe keine Informationen
bekommen sie haben mir meinen Flug
umgebucht und der wurde dann auch
gcancelt jetzt warte ich bis die
nächsten Schritte angekündigt werden
also ich will weinen ich will auch
schreien wer jetzt aber nicht ver nutzen
weil es ist erstens Zeit ich dafür
aufgewendet habe das Geld und dann steht
man halt doch da ein halber Meter
Neuschnee begräbt Teile Süddeutschlands
unter sich schon früh am Morgen
schaufeln sie sich im Bayerischen Wald
den Weg frei hier und im Rest des
freistats kommt es zu
Stromausfällen nah und Fernverkehr
stehen still die Deutsche Bahn stellt
für heute den Betrieb in München
vollständig ein rechnet in
Süddeutschland mit starken Störungen bis
Montag extrem wettergisse werden auch
häufiger und H fehl an der Vorbereitung
auch an der politischen Fokus dass die
Deutsche Bahn sich daruf konzentriert
dass sie es hinkriegt auch dass sie
ausreichend Geld hat auch abseits Derad
leiser geht es nur langsam vorwärts die
Behörden warnen vor Spaziergängen Bäume
und Äste könnten unter dem Schnee
einbrechen besser sei es zu Hause im
Warmen auszuharen am Flughafen würden
sie das wohl gerne tun bis z hin heßt es
aber
improvisieren tja Alexander Pool steht
in München in der Nähe des Bahnhofs ist
das Ärgste jetzt
überstanden das hängt ein bisschen vom
Wetterbericht ab morgen ist eigentlich
sonnefer gesagt dann könnte das Ergste
überstanden sein aber das war schon ein
heftiger Tag heute 40 cm Neuschnee in
München über 70 in anderen Teilen
Bayerns das hat man seit Jahrzehnten
hier nicht mehr gemessen sie können
hinter mir die zugeschneiten ICE Züge
sehen das sind die Züge die heute
eigentlich vom Münchner Hauptbahnhof aus
fahren sollten und dem Zusammenhang gibt
es tatsächlich auch Vorwürfe vom
Fahrgastverband probahn der sagt na ja
das Züge nicht fahren bei solchen
Witterungen das ist klar aber das gar
nichts mehr fährt das alles ausfällt da
hätte die Deutsche Bahn besser
vorbereitet sein müssen man verweist auf
Österreich da sei das besser gelaufen
und da ein ähnliches Bild er gibt sich
für uns am Flughafen tausende
gestrandete Passagiere der Flughafen
selbst sagt uns er tut was er kann um
sozusagen den Leuten hier zu helfen aber
unsere Beobachtungen zeigen auch das
reicht bei weitem nicht aus die Leute
wissen zum Teil nicht wo sie hin sollen
man kann sich in München auch kein Hotel
buchen weil es fährt nichts nach München
sofern bleibt auch hier nur die Hoffnung
auf besseres Wetter morgen Eindrücke aus
dem verschneiten München München danke
schön Alexander
Pool ein arbeitsreiches Wochenende für
die Spitzen der Ampelkoalition sie
müssen sich auf einen haushaltsentwrf
fürs kommende Jahr einigen damit er noch
vor Weihnachten verabschiedet werden
kann nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts klafft eine
Lücke von 17 Milliarden Euro sagt
Finanzminister Lindner über den Streit
ums Geld berichtet Frank
buchweit sparen aber wie darüber
streitet Berlin seit Tagen SPD
Generalsekretär künert heute Gast bei
den Genossen in Thüringen plädiert für
Einkommensgrenzen bei der
heizungsförderung und bringt neue
Steuern ins Spiel ist ja eine irre Sache
wer riesige Immobilien in de des besitzt
kann 10 Jahre lang die Abschreibung
nutzen und kann die Gewinne danach
steuerfrei mitnehmen und das wildeste
ist das Spiel kann D der nächst
weitermachen wieder 10 Jahre wieder
steuerfrei Christian Lindner setzt
andere Prioritäten im Zeitungsinterview
nennt der Finanzminister drei Bereiche
in denen er sparen möchte soziales
internationale Finanzhilfen und
Förderprogramme fast jeder zweite Euro
fließe in den Sozialhaushalt besonders
beim Bürgergeld müsse die Hilfe
treffsicherer werden
es geht darum Menschen schneller in
Arbeit zu bringen das nützt den Menschen
und das nützt dem Bundeshaushalt für die
geflüchteten aus der Ukraine kommt z.B
ein
jobturbo Schritte in die richtige
Richtung sagt die Union sie nennt aber
noch weitere Sparmöglichkeiten etwa die
bündlung familienpolitischer Leistungen
jedoch die Kindergrundsicherung ist so
wie sie jetzt angedacht ist
problematisch und zwar einfach wegen des
wahnsinnig hohen Bürokratie Aufwand und
der vielen Stellen im öffentlichen
Dienst die wir dann wieder zur
Verwaltung dieser Grundsicherung
einsetzen müssten noch am Wochenende so
heißt es in Berlin hinter vorgehaltener
Hand wollten die Spitzen der Koalition
sich im Kanzleramt treffen um Auswege
aus der Krise zu
beraten zwei Tage nach Ende der
Feuerpause herrscht wieder Krieg im
Nahen Osten israel will nach wie vor die
Terrororganisation Hamas vernichten man
habe mehr als 400 Ziele im abgeriegelten
Gasastreifen angegriffen besonders
schwere Kämpfe gibt es im Süden rund um
die Stadt hananunes dorthin sind viele
Palästinenser aus dem Norden geflohen
auch die Hamas feuerte wieder zahlreiche
Raketen auf Israel ab luten
linhus rette sich wer kann sie versuchen
wegzulaufen vor den Einschlägen auf der
Suche nach einem schützenden Ort den es
hier nicht
gibt der zweite Tag des bombenhagels ein
Albtraum für die Zivilbevölkerung in
hananjunis die Verletzten stürmen in die
ohnehin überfüllten Krankenhäuser hoffen
of vergeblich auf Behandlung und Hilfe
die Menschen wissen nicht mehr wohin so
der Sprecher von
uniceef diese Klinik kann keine weiteren
Kinder mit Kriegsverletzungen mehr
aufnehmen überall sind hier Kinder eine
Bombe ist nur 50 m von hier
eingeschlagen Israels Armee fordert die
Bevölkerung auf eine neue
evakuierungskarte zu nutzen sie teilt
den Gasastreifen in Hunderte Sektoren
informiert über aktive Kampfzonen und
rätt zur Flucht in andere Bezirke im
Norden des Gazastreifens gibt es heftige
Kämpfe israelische Bodentruppen gehen
gegen hamasterroristen vor und zerstören
deren
kommandozentral nach Angaben der
israelischen Armee entdecken die
Soldaten dabei ein geheimes Raketenlager
der Hamas dutzende Geschosse versteckt
unter Ausrüstung des un-hilfswerks für
palästinensische Flüchtlinge unwah in
Tel Aviv demonstrieren am Abend wieder
Tausende auf dem Platz der Geiseln auch
jadens Schwester ist noch
entführt jeder Tag zählt jede Minute
geht es den Geisen schlechter so viele
dort sind
verletzt die Verhandlungen über eine
erneute Feuerpause hat israels Regierung
heute abgebrochen und auch die Hamas
teilt mit keine Geiseln mehr
freizulassen bis der Krieg beendet
ist seit bald zwei Jahren läuft der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und kein Ende ist absehbar gerade erst
hat Präsident Putin angekündigt seine
Armee erneut um etwa 170 000 Soldaten zu
vergrößern viele die auf ukrainischer
Seite kämpfen sind von Anfang an und
fast ohne Ablösung im Einsatz derzeit
etwa bei
avdiivka unser Reporter Tim Kröger zeigt
was das
bedeutet es war eine russische Kamik dr
die die ukrainischen Soldaten Vikor
mikola verletzt hat wegen der
anhaltenden Kämpfe konnten sie erst nach
Stunden vom Schlachtfeld indka gerettet
werden sie greifen die ganze Zeit an wir
verlieren sehr viele Jungs man hat keine
Kraft mehr gegen sie zu kämpfen sie
beschießen uns mit Artillerie und
drohen seit Oktober versuchen tausende
russische Soldaten auf dika offenbar
unter hohen eigenen Verlusten zu erobern
aber auch die Ukrainer erleiden Verluste
regelmäßig werden verwundete zum
sogenannten stabilisierungspunkt hinter
der Front
gebracht es tut so weh das zu sehen
besonders wenn der verwundete der dort
liegt keine Beine mehr hat und fragt was
ist mit meinen Bein das ist sehr
schwer besonders dann wenn sie gar nicht
mehr helfen sondern nur noch den Tod
feststellen
können das ist der Ehemann Sohn oder
Vater von
jemandem wir finden Briefe der Familien
Fotos der Familien Fotos der Kinder der
Soldaten das ist sehr
traurig und wie viele andere Soldaten
ist Arzt olexandre seit fast Z Jahren im
Einsatz sieht seine Familie seinen
vierjährigen Sohn kaum den Preis den die
Menschen in der Ukraine für diesen Krieg
bezahlen ist
unermesslich drit Tag der Klimakonferenz
dort rief heute eine Gruppe von 20
Staaten zum Ausbau der Atomkraft auf um
die Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energien
zu verringern unterzeichnet haben unter
anderem die USA Frankreich und
Großbritannien Deutschland nicht
deutlich mehr Einigkeit gibt es bei den
erneuerbaren Energien die sollen massiv
ausgebaut werden aus Dubai Mark
Hugo Windräder werden aufgestellt
Solarpanele installiert fast überall auf
der den Planeten der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren geht voran für das 1,5°
Limit von Paris aber noch nicht schnell
genug eines der Topthemen in Dubai auch
in der Rede des Bundeskanzlers vor dem
konferenzplenum machen wir den Ausbau
erneuerbareer Energien zur
energiepolitischen Priorität Nummer 1
weltweit einigen wir uns hier in Dubai
auf zwei verbindliche Ziele z. einen auf
die Verdreifachung des Ausbaus
erneuerbare Energien und z anderen auf
die Verdoppelung der Energieeffizienz
beides bis 2030 neben Deutschland haben
sich heute mehr als 100 Länder für
dieses Ziel stark gemacht die Chancen
auf den ersten Beschluss globaler
Ausbauziele überhaupt stehen gut er
könnte die Dynamik verstärken während
gegenüber 2015 die Investitionen in
fossile Energien leicht rückläufig sind
nehmen die in erneuerbare deutlich zu
dennoch der Kanzler als klimakanzler
umweltschützer kritisieren das er weiter
auch ein Erdgas festhält es kann nicht
sein dass der Kanzler in einem Atemzug
vom Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien und
weiteren Investition in neue fossile
gasinfrastruktur spricht von dieser
Weltklimakonferenz muss ein eindeutiges
Signal ausgehen nämlich das jetzt
schluss ist mit den fossilen Energien
Schluss mit Gas Kohle und Öl auch
darüber wird in Dubai hart verhandelt
eine Einigung gilt als
unwahrscheinlich in Afrika bringt der
klimawand viele an den Rand ihrer
Existenz wochenlange Überschwemmungen
haben im Osten des Kontinents viel Land
verwüstet ernten vernichtet mehr als 2
Millionen Menschen in Somalia
Äthiopien und in Kenia mussten vor den
Fluten fliehen zetausende haben Schutz
gesucht in Camps wie in madogo Alexander
glotzinski
berichtet mehr istoka nicht geblieben
ein paar Tücher Töpfe und ihr Handy FL
ihr Dorf erreichte ist sie mit ihrem
Sohn gelaufen so schnell sie
konnte wir konnten dort nicht mehr
bleiben weil uns das Wasser bis zum Hals
Stand seit vi Wochen leben etwa 1500
Menschen aus ihrem Ort in Zelten vom
Roten Kreuz an Kenias größtem Fluss sind
die Menschen auf sich allein
gestellt wir müssen die Büsche als
Toilette benutzen und in unseren Zelten
haben wir kein Wasser und kein
Essen überschwemmte Felder und Dörfer
Wassermassen nach den heftigen
Regenfällen haben alles mitgerissen die
einzige Straße nach Garissa in die
größte Stadt der Region ist verschwunden
diese Straße wurde vor einer Woche von
den Fluten weggeschwemmt die Menschen
hier sind darauf angewiesen durch den
Fluss zu warten um Ihre Einkäufe
Lebensmittel und Benzin zu
transportieren eine ganze Region ist von
der Versorgung abgeschnitten in garisa
selbst werden die Vorräte knapp weil den
Verkäufern der Nachschub fehlt auch das
sind extremwetterfolgen wenn das Klima
aus dem Gleichgewicht
gerät Regenfälle werden in dieser Region
das neue normal sein verglichen damit
wie es bisher
waroka sieht ihr zerstörtes Haus zum
ersten Mal nach ihrer Flucht der Schock
ist groß nichts ist mehr
übrig ich will nicht mehr zurückkommen
ohne Haus und Platz wo ich bleiben kann
ihre Heimat wird sie verlassen weil
zunehmende Fluten diesen Ort für Sie
unbewohnbar
machen
Deutschland im vergangenen Winter Eltern
mussten mit ihren kranken Kindern von
Klinik zu Klinik fahren bis sie endlich
einen freien Platz fanden Operationen
mussten verschoben werden vor allem
wegen zu wenig Personal aber auch weil
Medikamente und Geld fehlten Deutschland
in diesem Winter die Probleme der
Kinderkliniken sind ungelöst wieder
zeichnen sich engpesse ab senjaer
berichtet oft muss es schnell gehen alle
säutlinge hier auf auf der
Kinderintensivstation sind schwerst
krank und müssen rund um die Uhr
überwacht werden der kleine ASAT wartet
auf eine
Lungentransplantation sein Gerät PT ja
fast alle paar Minuten da muss immer
jemand vorbeikommen also er kann kaum
atmen
sättigt nicht so gut und dieser defekt
gefekt ist auch nicht heilbar die
Schwestern geben ihr Bestes doch sie
sind chronisch unterbesetzt fast 40% der
Betten stehen hier wegen Personalmangels
leer obwohl Patienten sie dringend
bräuchten für die Pflegenden bedeutet
das mehr und schnelleres Arbeiten dieser
Spagat zwischen ich versorge in Ruhe
aber habe eigentlich nicht die
Möglichkeit weil die Leute fehlen und
weil ich keine Zeit habe dieser diesen
Spagat hinzubekommen ist unglaublich
schwer und manchmal leidet man halt dann
selber drunter dass man zu wenig trinkt
zu wenig istst die Situation sei
angespannt und könnte sich zuspitzen
wenn die infektwelle erst richtig
beginnt denn dann werden nicht nur
patientenkrank sondern auch Personal
Ärzte fordern endlich bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen und dazu gehört
eigentlich eine größere Zahl an
fliegenden das heißt es sehr wichtig in
den Nachwuchs zu investieren und müssen
auch natürlich ökonomisch etwas tun das
heißt denke ich insbesondere diese
unattraktiven Schichten am Wochenende an
feuertagen oder auch nachts müssten
besser vergütet werden die Versorgung
der schwächsten sei gewährleistet so die
Kliniken weniger schwere Fälle müssten
allerdings jetzt schon täglich an zum
Teil weit entfernte Krankenhäuser
abgegeben werden okay so und jetzt
freuen wir uns mit den frisch gebackenen
U17 Weltmeistern und die hatten ja schon
vor genau 6 Monaten das
emendspiel gewonnen ebenfalls gegen
Frankreich ebenfalls im Elfmeter
schießen ja und heute nun in Indonesien
die Neuauflage des finalkrimmis
Deutschland holt erstmals den WM-Titel W
das Happy End nach einer emotionalen
Achterbahnfahrt der Dortmunder
paris-brunner bringt die DFB Auswahl
nach einer knappen halben Stunde per 11
Meter in Führung in der zweiten Halbzeit
erhöht zunächst Deutschland auf 2:0
durch den früheren Freiburger Noah
darwig doch Frankreich nur 2 Minuten
später schon wieder mit dem
Anschlusstreffer durch Bua PR
Deutschland dann nach einer gelbroten
Karte für den Leipziger osave in
Unterzahl Frankreich kann daraus Kapital
schlagen amagu mit dem 2:2 es geht ins
meteter schießen wo der Dortmunder
almogera ka den WM Triumph perfekt
macht solchen widererständen zu kämpfen
selbst im met schießen wieder hinten zu
liegen immer an sich zu glauben das ist
unglaublich dieser WM-Titel ist ein
Hoffnungszeichen für den zuletzt so
gebeutelten deutschen
Fußball und jetzt zur Fußball EM 2024
hier bei uns in Deutschland da wurden
soeben in Hamburg die Gruppen ausgelost
das dfbteam trifft in der Gruppe A auf
Schottland und Ungarn und die Schweiz ja
Sven Foss in Hamburg wie sind denn die
ersten
Reaktionen ja große Freude viel Respekt
aber keine Angst vor diesen
Gruppengegnern ich konnte eben mit dem
Sportdirektor Rudi Föller und auch mit
Bundestrainer Julian nagelsmann sprechen
und beide waren sich einig dieses
Eröffnungsspiel gegen Schottland das
wird was ganz Besonderes weil es wird
ein sehr sehr stimmungsvolles und
ansonsten heißen die Gegner Ungarn und
auch Schweiz da sind natürlich viele
viele Bekannte aus der Bundesliga dabei
und da schaut man sicherlich ganz ganz
besonders hin und für Julian nagelsmann
beginnt jetzt die ganz konkrete Arbeit
jetzt stehen die Gegner fest das heißt
Anfang nächsten Jahres werden dann auch
die ersten Testspielgegner feststehen
denn man will sich natürlich genau auf
diese Mannschaften aus der Gruppe
einstellen können also viel Freude hier
dass es endlich losgeht in Hamburg danke
Sven danke nach Hamburg zum 13 Spieltag
der Fußballbundesliga in München wurde
ja das Spiel gegen Union wegen des
schneeaos abgesagt hier die bisherigen
Ergebnisse München Union Berlin also
verlegt Leipzig schlägt Heidenheim 2:1
Gladbach Hoffenheim ebenfalls Z1 Bochum
Wolfsburg 3:1 das Abendspiel Stuttgart
gegen Bremen bereits gestern Darmstadt
Köln 0:1 die Tabelle Leverkusen erster
vor den Bayern dahinter Stuttgart
Leipzig erstmal vierter vor Dortmund und
Hoffenheim die zweite Tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit Freiburg ja und unten
Darmstadt Mainz und Schlusslicht Union
Berlin das Abendspiel stuttgart-bremen
ausführlich bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr zu Gast der des
Deutschen Olympischen Sportbundes Thomas
Weikert Andreas Wellinger ist beim
Skisprung weleltcup in Lillehammer
Zweiter geworden schon sein zweiter
Podestplatz nach drei saisonwettbewerben
Sieger der Österreicher Stefan
Kraft ja und wieder ein deutscher Erfolg
beim Biathlon Weltcup in Östersund
Philip navrat sorgt nach fehlerfreiem
schießen für die große Überraschung und
gewinnt den 10 km Sprint sein erster
weltcupsieg
überhaupt und das war's vom Sport an
diesem weltmeisterlichen Samstag danke
schön war ein eine Freude Vorsicht auf
Straßen und Gehwegen da könnte es glatt
sein in manchen Regionen strahlt Morgen
die Sonne über dem Neuschnee Details hat
gleich Katja hornffer Marietta slomker
begrüßt sie um 10 Uhr im heutejournal
und wir wünschen Ihnen ein schönes
Wochenende bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend so viel Neuschnee auch in
großen Städten Süddeutschlands wie passa
oder München gab es wohl schon seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr und es wurden
wohl auch einige altzeitrekorde geknackt
in den Mittelgebirgen und in
Süddeutschland bleibt dieser Schnee auch
liegen die schneefäler am Alpenrand
lassen jetzt in der Nacht allerdings
nach weitere Schneewolken ziehen über
Niedersachsen weiter Richtung
SachsenAnhalt und Thüringen im Westen
ist es zum Teil auch klar dann bildet
sich Nebel und über den Schneeflächen in
Süddeutschland sinken die Temperaturen
bei Aufklaren bis
-15° das wird also eine sehr frostige
Nacht und morgen verlassen uns diese
Schneewolken ostwärts und zum späten
Nachmittag und Abend beginnt es hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und in Niedersachsen
erneut zu schneien für viele von uns
wird das morgen ein sehr sonniger erster
Advent mit Sonnenschein über Neuschnee
Flächen und nur noch wenigen
Schneeschauern bei Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen -4 und + 4°. die neue Woche
startet winterlich und da es von
Südwesten milder wird wird es auch
wieder gefährlich glatt auf den Straßen
wenn nämlich der Regen auf den
gefrorenen Boden fällt am Montag ist das
eher im Westen am Dienstag eher im Osten
der Fall ich wünsche ihn einen schönen
ersten
Advent